We're in a massive process of de norming.
We are unraveling every standard, uh,
in the name of racial justice. So what happened in your car?
That's, that's a product of largely of proposition 47.
Uh, one of the ballot initiatives in California that downgraded a whole bunch of
felonies, including felony theft, uh,
to misdemeanor status because of the problem of
criminal laws, having a disparate impact on my.
You think it's funny.
That the, that the billionaires that are thought of as the good guy,
billionaire. So, you know, bill Gates is thought of as good.
Let's say Warren buffet is thought of as good, you know, Koch brothers, bad,
or whoever the right ones are bad, but the ones that are thought of as good,
they sort of think that they can give away enough money or say enough things
that it will save them, but it will never save them right. In the,
I ultimately have the base, no matter they could give away everything,
they can destroy their fortunes and empires, and it just will never end.
You think they just don't realize that, or it's like,
you just have to do it no matter what, because you want to survive.
Do they not realize that? Yeah, I don't, they don't really have a choice. Um,
but they are playing with fire. I mean, they have to realize that the,
to the extent that they continue feeding this and Marc Benioff is just a great
example. There he is in,
in San Francisco promoting this idea that the San Francisco has not done enough
to help the homeless. And, you know,
we need to save the children and what not through just endless
bulking up of the bureaucracy,
without dealing with the profound questions of norms,
public norms of behavior, uh, you know,
he probably thinks he can buy a exoneration, but it's just,
it's not going to happen. Because again, it's all connected. You know,
this the same left that is,
has been dominating homeless politics in San Francisco for
decades, the coalition on homelessness,
they are connected to the entire woke, uh,
discourse, whether it's regards to illegal aliens or, uh,
you know, white supremacy or male toxic masculinity, it's all,
it's all part of the same thing.
So let's shift actually towards the homeless portion of this. Cause I,
I watched this morning a talk that you did about the San Francisco situation,
which everyone knows is horrific. I've told this story a million times,
but when I was there about a year ago,
I went out to dinner with a friend and we were at Morton steakhouse.
So it's a nice street. We're on supposedly nice street.
Our car got broken into right outside the restaurant.
They stole my bag and my notebook and all this stuff.
And I took a picture of the broken glass and I tweeted it out and I kid you not,
I got hundreds. If not thousands of responses,
basically all saying the same thing, Dave,
what kind of idiot leaves a bag in a car in San Francisco?
Because there is such an epidemic of break-ins that they know that
regular people know not to leave a bag in a car. What is happening up there?
Well, it's happening across the country.
We're in a massive process of de norming.
We are unraveling every standard, uh,
in the name of racial justice. So what happened in your car?
That's, that's a product of largely of proposition 47,
uh, one of the ballot initiatives in California that downgraded a whole bunch of
felonies, including felony theft, uh,
to misdemeanor status because of the problem of
criminal laws, having a disparate impact on minorities.
Do you think the people that are pushing these laws that it's the road to hell
is paved with good intentions, always.
Do you think that they really think they're doing something good,
even though all the evidence always points to the fact that it gets worse after
these policies are?
I don't? I think I've, you've said yourself,
you're not a big fan of conspiracy theories. I'm not either. I really,
I take people if their words,
I think that they really do believe that the
overrepresentation of blacks in prison is due to criminal justice racism.
And that we're throwing a whole bunch of,
of trivial offenders in prison, which is not the case.
You have to work very hard to get yourself a prison sentence, most,
any big city you're triaged out. Uh, you know,
if you steal somebody's car,
a da is going to be completely uninterested in you.
You have to steal it at gunpoint with the driver's still in to get a big city da
interested in actually prosecuting your case,
as opposed to just giving you probation and sending you on your way. Uh, but no,
I think that they, they really do believe that, uh,
the criminal justice system is racist and that the way to solve that is to,
is to not prosecute,
not put people not and defang the police.
And of course the problem is yes,
there's a vast over representation of blacks in prison.
But the thing we should be concerned about is that blacks are victimized by
crime the most.
And I go to community meetings in inner city
neighborhoods all the time,
those good law abiding Borzois residents of high crime neighborhoods,
beg for more police protection. Those are the voices that never get hurt.
So when these policies are put in place or like in New York city,
the Blasio has now done this thing where you're allowed to jump the turnstile,
they will not stop you. So it's like,
you're basically saying to everybody that pays. Yeah. Right.
And I lived in New York city. Most of my adult life, I never jumped a turnstile.
You're basically saying if you pay, you're an idiot, like why should you do it?
And so they're actually encouraging more and more people to not fall.
I know. And AOC has as well. I mean,
this is really for a politician to defend turnstile
should be, that's an impeachable offense because
social norms are fragile and respect for the
rule for the rule of law is the essence of a civilization.
We lose that and you get third world anarchy with everybody trying to
game the system. You know, queuing is a thing of beauty.
We take it for granted,
but for people to be able to quietly wait in line and wait their place as
opposed to trying to, you know, get to the top and just muscle,
everybody else out, break the rules, whatever to get ahead, that is, uh,
you know, has been in sort of normal condition.
And for respect for the rule for the law is incredibly precious.
And to say it doesn't matter and the police should walk on by,
you are playing with fire, you are on the road to anarchy.
You sense that we're in a much more precarious place right now related to that
then than we've ever been, or at least, or maybe in the last,
let's say 50 years, something like that.
We have this extraordinary revolution that nobody foresaw in the 1990s
in the eighties,
the reigning wisdom unlock enforcement itself was that
police could do nothing about crime.
That crime was a product of inequality and injustice.
And until you solve poverty and, and economic inequalities,
all the police could do would respond after the fact. So why even bother.
Likewise New York city and especially times square was a drug den. When,
when I was growing up, going into the city.
Because you just police were just walking by the FBI,
publishes an annual crime report throughout the eighties,
they had a disclaimer saying, well,
of course we know homicide is a social problem that the police can't solve.
So the nineties had this incredible
profound moment where that whole ideology of passivity
before social anarchy was turned on its head.
And you had mayor Giuliani coming in Giuliani. And his good days,
I don't know what's happened to them now. It's very depressing to me,
but he was the great one of the greatest mayors,
if not the greatest mayor New York ever had.
And his police commissioner William Bratton said, no, we are actually going to,
the police are going to lower crime by enforcing the law.
And we learned that enforcement matters. You change people's behavior,
you deter criminal offending.
And they started paying attention to those low level crimes in times square,
the squall or the, the,
the turnstile jumping that graffiti the urinating in the streets.
And they changed public norms. And,
and the whole broken windows theory is correct.
And even if it doesn't prevent higher level crimes,
it's what people in high crime neighborhoods beg for.
They want public order on the streets. And now that is all being thrown away.
And again, the reason is disparate impact. So, all right. So as.
Someone that deals in fact, and that's what your books have been about,
and that's why my audience digs what you do.
Do you ever find that sometimes facts just aren't enough to
change the discourse? So it's like, all right, well, okay.
We could probably move on. So how do you, how do you deal with that then?
Because I find this to be like the most, um,
sort of strangest place for conservatives to be right now,
which is that most of the facts seem to be on the conservative side of things at
the moment. Like, it just seems to be reality right now,
but I think conservatives have a really hard time breaking through either the
cultural part. I think that's actually really changing right now,
partially because of Trump. Um,
but sometimes facts just aren't enough, right? I mean,
I was telling you right when you sat down,
but we were talking about the homeless thing,
the target that's a half mile from my house.
There is a massive homeless encampment, massive. I mean,
it's like a city there now when I go to target and it's like, well, I,
we could talk about why some of the reasons that you just laid out are allowing
this to expand, but a lot of people don't want to hear that.
Well, you know,
this is something that you have been thinking about for much longer than I have
of how do you change minds?
What is the nature of rational discourse? What is its limits?
And, you know,
we learned from people like Jonathan Haidt that in fact reason,
often acts as a,
after the fact justification for people's instinctive
value systems and ways of looking at the world. So, well,
I would like to claim non ironically that I have the facts on my side.
And in fact, I believe that, I mean, that's what drives me.
And it's sort of a hatred of what I call idiocy.
I have to acknowledge that the Progressive's would say the
same thing.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.